hey what is going on youtube check it
out so today's going to be a quick
announcement video where I'm going to
share some future products that do with
you guys and also a few announcements so
before we get started I want y'all to
check me out and this page called my ish
and basically either this one quick
little cameo call ish list so if you
guys want to check that out it's really
don't buy basically go down and talk
about my seven top favorite songs of a
certain genre um find out on the channel
so it's gonna be right here on this
little link on below is this is this
work right there anyways huge
announcement um you guys have been
asking for shirts for a while now but I
didn't want to put out tricks that I
really didn't think that you guys would
wear so this is gonna be the first chef
design i'm gonna show you guys right now
my brother actually designed this and my
cousin from fire from studios actually
digitizes for me so as you can see it
says LGI for a lift get it right there
and this is a panda kind of version of
my face it's the first design out of
many so go ahead and cut that out peep
it out if you want to buy it's gonna be
on my big cartel in a couple of weeks
i'm a post up that late later on in my
videos and go ahead and get goin invite
if you like i had of course at the end
of video imma take this time to thank
you guys once again thank you very much
about boys puberty be a lot of you have
been asking also like how long have I
been doing this YouTube thing it's only
been about a year i'm relatively under
the game i started this thing because i
was going to school at the time um and I
really couldn't get out there and put my
material because I was you know working
so many part-time jobs you know doing
schools trying to do music at the time
too and also comedy and I really
couldn't get out there and push my
material so i decided to use YouTube
finding out that you know how powerful
of a social media to it was so you know
myself out there and i'ma let you guys
take my stuff so uh yeah so anyways
thanks for the support and I will see
you all soon talk to you later takeoff
checks uh [ __ ] them i say cut
he's my friend she called me